[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من
العربيه انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه اخبار
الظهيره مشاهدينا نبداها بالعناوين
الامن الايراني
لاغاثه المحتجين
ردا على تفجير اسطنبول تركيا تدق ساعه
الحساب قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تحذر من
فاجعه
يقول ان وقفه اطلاق النار لا يضمن السلام
ويؤكد ان روسيا تبحث عن استراحه لقواتها
بعد غياب عندما عامين ترامب يعود الى
تويتر والشركه تنتظر موجه اقالات
واستقاله جديده
مشاهدينا البدايه من الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
التي تتسع رقعتها وشملت عشرات المدن حصيله
الضحايا ترتفع يوميا من الضحايا نتحدث عن
مئات المتظاهرين الذين فقدوا ابصارهم او
تعرضت اعينهم لاضرار بالغه وفقا لصحيفه
نيويورك هذه الاضرار هي نتيجه استهدافهم
من قبل قوات الامن بالرصاص المطاطي
والكرات المعدنيه خلال الاحتجاجات في
محاوله لتفريق المحتجين وفقا للصحيفه
اظهرت روايات الشهود عيان واكثر من 80
صفحه من السجلات الطبيه من المستشفيات عده
ان نطاق الاصابات شبكيه عين مشوهه وايضا
اعصاب بصريه
العين الروايات الحيه هذه اكدت ان الكثير
منهم حرموا من العلاج في معتقل البعض
الاخر
عمليات جراحيه كيف لا ولي للمصاب خيار سوى
الذهب للعلاج في المستشفيات والعيادات
كلها حكوميه والتي غالبا ما تحرسها قوات
الامن طبعا مع استمرار الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه على مدى شهرين تنتاب النظام
الايراني حاله من القلق من تكرار سيناريو
اسقاط الشافي عام 79 حتى حذر المرشد
الايراني علي خامنه من اي يحاول من وصفهم
باعداء ايران من حشد العمال للدخول في
اضرابات قال في كلمه بثها التليفزيون
الرسم قال ان من وصفهم بالاعداء ربما
يستهدفون الطوائف المختلفه ك- العمال
وايضا النساء طبعا تحذيرات خامنه لتاتي في
وقت زادت فيه رقعه الاحتجاجات لتصل جامعه
ايرانيه في مدن مختلفه اذا مظاهرات في
الجامعات واخرى تتواصل في الشارع الايراني
مقطع فيديو متداول اظهر والد احد القتل
الذين سقطوا على يد قوات الامن الايراني
وهو وحيد دمور الفيديو
ظهر واظهر هذا الوالد والد الضحيه وهو يعد
الطعام ليقدمه طبعا للمتظاهرين وهذا طبعا
نوع من انواع الدعم وايضا المساعده لهم
متابعه
[موسيقى]
الصيام
في مناطق مختلفه اضافه لما ذكرناها قبل
قليل من مخاوف من النظام الايراني
صالح حميد اهلا بك استاذ صالح اسمح لي انا
ابدا بقضيه الاستهدافات في الاعين هل هي
استراتيجيه جديده يمكن القول او لا هذا
معتاد بالنسبه لنظام مثل هذه التظاهرات
النظام الحقيقي
البارحه شهدنا انه استخدم حتى همم ذخائر
حربيه خاصه في مناطق كردستان الايرانيه في
مدينه مهبات في سلندش في بوكان في المدن
المنتفظه خاصه تلك التي تخرج عن سيطره
النظام ليلا وتصبح المحتجين راينا يعني
حتى انتشار مدرعات ودبابات في شوارع
مهابات هناك تهديد من النظام بالهجوم على
المدينه من قبل القوات الحرس الثوري
والقوات الامن الخاصه الاستهداف في الواقع
همم طال للاطفال والنساء اليوم همم وكاله
ارانا الحقوقيه الايرانيه ومن قارها في
نيويورك اعلنت ان عدد القتلى وصل الى همم
410 اكثر من 50 طفل بينهم
نحكي مش اليس فقط استهدافات ولكن اصابات
وهناك ما خوف من الذهاب الى المستشفيات
لان كلها حكوميه والحرس الثوري يسيطر
عليها هذا هو الواقع ولا فقط الان في ظل
الاحتجاجات
يعني يستخدم بعض الاسلحه بنادق الصيد لكي
يقول ان مسلحين هم من يستخدموها همم ايضا
يلاحق الاطباء الذين يعالجون همم المصابين
في المنازل يعني انتشر فيديو لاحد الاطباء
همم وهو همم تعرض الى الضرب وكان بما تنزف
من كل انحاء جسمه فقط لانه قام بواجبه
المهني وقدم خوفا من الذهاب الى المستشفى
كل من يذهب الى المستشفيات لتلقي العلاج
والنظام يحاول التقليل من عدد القتله لك
لا يصبح سيناريو مثل ما حدث في نوفمبر
2019 حيث همم قتلت قوات الامن والحرس
الثوره 1500 تظاهر الان ايضا العدد ليس
بقليل المنظمات تقول ان 410 هم من تم
توثيقهم لانه قتلوا
خليني اسال عن قضيه طبيعه ما يحدث على
الارض الان مقارنه ان كان ب 2000 2019 ان
كان ب 2009 او حتى ما يسار الان من مخاوف
من عوده ثوره على الشام
تصريحات خانه ايه كانت تدل على هذا
الارباك والخوف من نفس المصير لانه عايشه
الفتره الثوره عام 79 دامت لمده سنه كامله
في الواقع الان هذه الثوره ايضا دخلت
شهرها الثالث الظروف متشابهه ال همم
الظروف متشابهه على الارض ولكن هل الدعم
الخارجي ايضا متشابهه او لا بهذا الاسم
الذي مثلا
لكن ايضا هناك تبدل نشهد يعني تغيرا كبيرا
وقف المفاوضات همم الاوروبيين اعلنوا انهم
لن يتعاملوا مع الدبلوماسيين الايرانيين
او يرسم رسائل او يدعوهم همم هناك عقوبات
جديده الحقيقه يعني هذه الثوره استطاعه ان
تغير هذه المواقف كثيرا صحيح انها لم تصل
بعد الى المستوى المطلوب مثل البحث عن
بديل لهذا النظام لكن الجميع يراقب ما
يحدث في ايران همم
هناك همم شبان على اسم الطلا من يقودون
الحرام نقطه اصلاح النظام
وربما اطفاء بعض التعديلات على الدستور او
قلب النظام كله
الشعب يئس من وجود اي اصلاح لانه
المحتاجين يهتفون ايها الاصلاحين ايها
المتشددون لعبتكم قد انتهت
والشارع بتدرك ان هذا مجرد تبادل للادوار
صحيح ان شراره الثوره انطلقت بسبب العنف
ضد النساء همم ومنذ مقتل ماء امينه لكن
سرعان ما تحولت الى مطالب من قبل كل اشهر
على الاجتماع الان
وايضا تحول بالطعاطي الايراني مع هذه
التظاهرات طبعا مشاهدينا سنقمل الحديث
ولكن عن نقطه مهمه اخرى فيما يتعلق بتعاطي
النظام الايراني مع ما يحدث بالداخل ولكن
من خلال تحريك اذرعه في الخارج وبهذا
الاطار طبعا لدينا تصريحات من وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني هو في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه قال
واكد على وقوف بريطانيا مع دول الخليج
وحلفائها في المنطقه ضد التهديدات
الايرانيه عبر دعمها دفاعيا وايضا تحدث عن
الدعم المعلومات تدعونا نتابع
رصدنا بالفعل العديد من الهجمات من
مجموعات متعدده تابعه لايران ضد العديد من
الدول ومن دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وكنت في ابوظبي
عندما وقعت هجمه صاروخيه على منشات حيويه
نؤكد بصدق اننا نقف مع حلفائنا واصدقائنا
في المنطقه للدفاع عن امنهم ودعمهم للتصدي
للهجمه الارهابيه
داخل الشوارع والمدن الايرانيه هزت عده
مدن اخرى في الغرب ليصل ارتدادها لشوارع
عواصم بعينها وتظاهرات تهدد نظام منئي
وتهدد هذا النفوذ نظام يعلم حجم الرفض له
من خلال ما يظهر داخليا قد يكون بامكانه
قمع هذه المواقف بوسائل وحشيه لكنه بات
الان يستخدم ذات الاسلوب في قمع مع خارجيا
امر تدركه وتحذر منه الحكومات الغربيه
دعونا ايضا نتابع
هجره اصوات المعارض الشوارع مدن ايرانيه
عده ليصل ارتدادها لشوارع عواصم غربيه
تظاهرات تهدد نظام خامن ونفوذه نظام يعلم
حجم الرفض له داخليا قد يكون بامكانه
قموعها بوسائل وحشيه لكنه بات الان يستخدم
ذات الاسلوب في قمععارضه خارجيه امر تدركه
وتحذر منه الحكومات الغربيه
بشكل خاص اولئك الصحفيين الشجاع الذين
كشفوا ما تفعله الحكومه بحق الايراني تجب
حمايه المراسلين الذين يوفقون هذه
الاحتجاجات وستتم حمايتهم في بريطانيا لم
يكن هذا التحذير الاول من بريطانيا من خطر
التهديد الايراني
المدير العام لجهاز الاستخبارات الداخليه
البريطانيه نظام الايراني بمحاوله مع في
بريطانيا مشيرا الى قيام الاستخبارات
الايرانيه ب 10 محاولات على الاقل
في امريكا كشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان
ايران استعنت بصوره خفيه بمحققين امريكيين
خاصين لا يعلمون حقيقه العمل المطلوب منهم
او الجهه التي تقف وراءها لمتابعه وملاحقه
المعارضين الموجودين على الاراضي
الامريكيه ربما الدليل الاكبر الذي استندت
عليه الصحيفه ما حدث مع الصحفيه المعارضه
نصيحه
كلفته بملاحقه شخص اجنبي من قبل عميل غير
امريكي وبعد ايام من المراقبه اتصل عملاء
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي وقالوا انني
اعمل دون قصد لخدمه المخابرات الايرانيه
في مهمه لمراقبه الصحفيه المعارضه مسيحه
علينا جاد
تزوجت النظام الايراني خارج حدوده قائمه
تتسع يوما بعد يوم في كندا اعلن جهاز
الاستخبارات الكنديه انه يحققوا في
تهديدات بالقطر بناء على معلومات ذات
مصداقيه اطلقتها ايران ضد اشخاص على
الاراضي الكذبيه
هذه الانشطه الايرانيه الغذائيه والتدخل
الاجنبي يقود في نهايه المطاف امن كندا
والكنديين فضلا عن قيام من الديمقراطيه
وسيادتنا
استراتيجيه اسكره المعارضين الايرانيه
بالصوره فجه وعلانيه باتت محطه انظار
الدول الغربيه
الايراني العابره
اذا مشاهدينا الان نركز على الحديث حول
التحركات والانشطه الايرانيه خارج حدودها
وطالت تهديد وصل الى عدد من الصحفيين
وايضا تحركات اخرى وعود الى ضيف صالح حميد
حول هذه النقطه ماذا تقول لنا مثل هذه
التحركات الايرانيه في الخارج الايراني
يوصل صوت الايرانيين الى الخارج ولا لعب
دورا كبيرا في الواقع في تغيير هذه
المواقف الدوليه التي تحدثنا عنها لذلك
امتدت تهديداته ليس فقط في الداخل من سجن
الصحفيين وقمعهم الان هناك منذ بدايه هذه
الاحتجاجات اكثر من 50 صحفي بما فيه صحفيه
له فرح حامد التي نشرت خبر مقتل مساء
امينه همم هل هي تطال حياتهم هل يمكن
للايران ان يتجاوز كل الحدود الاعراف
الدبلوماسيه والاخلاقيه وكل شيء وان يتحرك
ضد الصحفيين ويؤثر على حياتهم يستهدفهم
يعني حدث ضد الصحفي روح الله زم تم
استدراجه من فرنسا الى العراق ومن هناك
خططف وسال لماذا ايران وتم اعدامه حدث ضد
مسيحي
مش بريطانيا مش بكندا
في الولايات المتحده كاراد ان يخطف صحفيه
مسيحيه للنجاد عن طريق فنزويلا ينقلها الى
ايران الحقيقه التهديدات لم تتوقف يوما ضد
صحفيه سواء بالضغط او تهديد ضده مباشره
تهديد بالاغتيال او مؤامره الاغتيال في
الواقع او الضغط على عوائلهم في الداخل
الكثير منها بما فيها نحن الذين يغطي شان
الايراني كل عوائل لنا اصدقاء
يعني استجوابات من الاستخبارات الحاره الى
تهديدات مستمره يعني دائما سواء من خلال
الرسائل المباشره عبر مواقع
في امور اخرى مطلوبه
لكم
في الرسائل هو الاسكات همم وعدم نشر ما
يحدث على ارض الواقع لان النظام استثمر
كثيرا عشرات القنوات مختلفه اللغات بما
فيه العربيه موجهه الى الخارج وموجه الى
الداخل والنظام يريد التعتيم لذلك يقوم
بقطع الانترنت يقوم بسجن الصحافيين يقوم
بتهديد الصحفيين والنشاطات في الخارج
الحمائي اذا ما صح التعبير بالنسبه
للصحفيين ما هو او انه القضيه القضيه همم
مقاومه بالنسبه لكم ونضال وبالتالي لا
توقف او انه الدول اللي بتكون موجودين
فيها تقدم مثل هذه الحمايه طبعا بعض الدول
تقدم الحمايه يعني انا انه في بريطانيا
وفي المانيا ايضا ارسلت الاجهزه السفارات
على الصحفيين وابلغتهم بهذه التهديدات
وعرضت لهم همم بعض همم
بحمايه بعض المؤسسات بس تتحدث عن افراد في
نوع من الحمايه الموجوده او الخوف قائم
ذلك
قائما ولكن اصح فينا ايضا يعتبرون انفسهم
في الجبهات الاماميه لنضال الشعب الايراني
وراينا الكثير منهم يعني همم خاصه في
الداخل ماتوا تحت التعذيب كثير من
المدونين والصحه الكاظمي المدون 46
والكثير منهم يعني كيف نتوقع ان يتعامل
الغرب مع هذه التهديدات خاصه انه مثبتته
جدا
دائما النظام يتهم جهات خارجيه بالتدخل
لكن التدخل في الواقع ان يكون صريحين كان
يتم دوما لصالح النظام وهذا معترف به
الرئيس الامريكي السابق اوباما قبل اسابيع
قال اننا في الانتفاضه الخضراء عام 2009
لم ندعم المتظاهرين وهذا كان خطا واقر انه
ذلك كان بتاثير من اللوبيات المقربه من
النظام الايراني لا زالت موجوده دائما
كانت يعني التدخل في ايران يحدث لصالح
الحكومه ضد الشعب وليس العكس كما يدعي
النظام الايراني سواء في 2009 في
الانتفاضه نفسها عام التي قام حتى في
الانتفاضه التي اسقطت الثوره التي اسقطت
الشاه كانت هناك يعني ثوره عاريمه شارك
بها كل القوى السياسيه لكن الغرب دعم
الخميني واتابير فرنسيه حدث مع مصدق ايضا
في ثوره مصدق حدث مع الاتيان بالشهر
قد تغير من المواقف الغربيه بدعم صالح
حميد الباحث في الشان الايراني شكرا
لتواجدك معنا
مشاهدينا طبعا نكمل اخبار الظهيره الان
ننتقل الى التطورات في تركيا تركيا اعلنت
اطلاق عمليه عسكريه ضد مسلحين اتراك في
شمال شرق سوريا وشمال ايضا العراق طبعا
المرصد السوري تحدث عن سقوط اثني عشر
قتيلا في القصف التركي نصفهم من قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه والنصف الاخر من قوات
النظام طبعا قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اتهمت
تركيا بشان ضربات على مناطق تحت سيطرتها
في محافظتي حلب والحسكي ومن ابرزها مدينه
كوباني المعروفه انقره من جانبها اعلنت
بعد القصف ان ساعه الحساب قد دقت مؤكده
على لسان وزاره الدفاع انها نفذ ضربات
جويه على قواعد للمسلحين الاكراد في شمال
سوريا وايضا في شمال العراق هذه العمليه
العسكريه تاتي بعد اسبوع من التفجير الذي
هز اسطنبول وقد حملت تركيا مس اهو لحزب
العمال الكردستاني الاكراد في سوريا
والعراق يلفون ان تكون لهم اي صله بتفجير
اسطنبول طبعا بهذا الاطار نشرت وزاره
الدفاع التركيه على حسابها في موقع تويتر
صوره
لمقاتله تقلع طبعا هذه هي المقاتله تقلع
لتنفيذ غاره ليليه في موقع لم تحدده دعانا
متابعه
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد حول هذه الغراض معنا من
اربيل مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني اهلا
بك احمد بدايه اي معلومات متوفره حول
المواقع الخسائر وغيرها من التفاصيل تفضل
يبدو انه الهدف الاول وطبعا سلسله جبال
قنديل تقع على الشمال من الشرق من اربيل
وايضا في شمال
لديها حدود مع محافظه السليمانيه وايضا مع
ايران ومع تركيا سلسله جبال قنديل سلسله
طويله ومعقده وتضاريس معقده جدا
واتاخذت منها اتخذ من حزب العمال كردستان
منذ التسعينات الماضي ما قرات وماذا ذات
ومنطلق لها جمعتهم ضد الجيش التركي
وبالتالي هي منطقه الصراع خارج نفود خارج
سيطره الامن العراقي
والدوله العراقيه بصوره مطلقه منذ ثلاث
عقود تحدث
معلومات
ليس هناك من امكانيه حتى الوصيل المعلومات
بمعنى اخر الاعتماد فقط على تصريحات
الرسميه التركيه
فقط هذا الجانب لروايه التركيه وربما هناك
تكون روايه
للاعلام مسلحين حزب العمال كردستاني عبر
قنواتهم اعلاميه وسالم الاعلام ولم توضح
حتى الان جبل قنديل في منطقه معقده كما
ذكرت وايضا فيها انفاق كثيره وفي نقاط
مكشوف ربما الطيران التركي لم يفارق جبل
قنديل منذ سنوات طيران مسيره يقصد
وبالتالي همم يحاول ان يحد من قدراتهم في
تلك المنطقه وهذا الجبل الذي هو يغذي
مقاتل لحزب العمال كردستاني في مناطق
كثيره من العراق سوريا
الامنيه العراقيه على الارض ولكن هذا لا
يمنع من هناك تحركات الان لتفعيل الحديث
في البرلمان عن التدخلات ان كانت
الايرانيه او التركيه ماذا نتوقع
طبعا الخطوه الاولى التي هي يتوقع يتوقعها
المراقبون طبعا هي ان يكون هناك تفعيل
لحرس الحدود العراقي على كافه حدود العراق
من ضمنها مناطق جبال قنديل ست سلسله جبال
قنديل عده كيلومترات خارج سيطره العراق
بصوره مطلقه مطلقه منذ ثلاث عقود بالنظام
صدام حسين وهمم طبعا ايضا
واجبار ايران على ان تحترم الحدود وتعود
بقوات حرس حدودها الى حدود الدوليه
المنصوص عليها
القوانينه المتحده كونها قد اجتازت الحدود
وتوكلت في الاراضي العراق وبنت هناك مخافر
حدوديه في المناطق خارج منطقه قنديل قنديل
فيها ليس فيها اي اي سيطره ما بين العراق
وايران بالتالي ايران وحرس الثوري ضباط
حرس الثوري قالت حرس الثوري قال اني
وفريقه اني كل همم جميعهم يلتقون بقنديل
وكانها بقعه ارض ايرانيه هذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه نتحدث عن قنديل هي جناح ايران حرس
الثور ايراني في تلك المنطقه مدعومه من
حرس الثوري وحرس الثور الذي يصول ويجول في
جبال قنديل وبالتالي ان تحرك البرلمان
والقرار السياسي فيكون ضمن همم
الاعتراف او ضمن تفعيل المخافر الحدوديه
على الحدود العراقيه سواء كان تركيا او مع
ايران او حتى مع سوريا
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل موظف سابق
في تويتر يقول ان امكانيه حدوث انقطاع
كبير في تويتر خلال المونديال تصل الى 50%
سنتابع
اهلا بكم مجددا المشاهدين الى اخبار
الظهيره ونكملها من تصريحات للرئيس
الامريكي السابق الدونال ترامب الذي قال
انه لا يهتم بالعوده الى تويتر حتى مع
تصويت اغلبيه ضئيله لصالح اعادته الى
المنصه طبعا لاستطلاع نظامها الملك الجديد
لهم ماسك خلاله اكثر من 15 مليون مستخدم
لصالح عوده ترامب طبعا بنسبه
51.8% كمان نشاهد من خلال هذه التغريده
وهذا التصويت ماسك غرد بعد وقت قصير من
اعلان نتائج الاستطلاع انه سيعيد حساب
الرئيس السابق لكن ترامب فاجاه الجميع فضل
الاستمرار في استخدام من قصته الوليده
تروس اي الحقيقه طبعا في اطار التصريحات
المتعلقه مستقبل تويتر بعد قرارات ماسكه
المختلفه خاصه تلك المتعلقه بتسريع عدد
كبير من الموظفين قال موظف سابق في تويتر
انه امكا حدوث انقطاع كبير في المنصه
اثناء بطوله كاس العالم تبلغ
50% طبعا هذا الموظف السابق والذي طلب عدم
الكشف عن هويته قال انه بين الافتقار الى
الاستعدادات وايضا نقص الموظفين فان كاس
العالم ستكون صعبه بالنسبه لمنصه تويتر
المتحدث اشار الى ان حادثه من نوع ما مثل
الخدمه البطيئه او غير الصحيحه تكاد تكون
مؤكده خلال منافسات المونديال طبعا هذه
التصريحات تصريحات الموظف السابق في تويتر
تاتي في وقت يرى فيه مراقبون ان احوال مصر
تويتر انقلبت راسا على عقب منذ تولي
الملياردير الامريكيه طبعا لهم ماسك قياده
الشركه وان مصيره تويتر اصبح مجهول بعد
تحذيرات من افلاس او حتى وصلت هذه
التحذيرات الى انهيار المنصه عنابه
الرؤيه في تويتر ضبابيه هل ينهار تويتر او
يفلس سؤال يتردد على لسان الجميع بعد
الفوضى العامه التي ضربت المنصه منذ ان
باتت في عهده الون ماسك
صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه تركت السؤال
عينه واعتبرت ان رد فعل ماسك على احدث
موجه فوضى في تويتر كانت مثيره للجدل
وغريبه عندما غرد بصوره قبر وعليها شعار
تويتر هذه الصوره دفعت بالكثيرين الى
التساؤل عما اذا كانت ازمه تويتر وجوديه
بالفعل
ماسك سر حا ما يقرب من نصف القوه العامله
في الموقع والبالغ عددها
750 موظفا في الاسبوع الاول من نوفمبر بعد
ايام على توليه مهمه قياده تويتر مما يعني
ان العدد المتبقي من الموظفين اصبح حوالي
ثلاثه الاف و 750 موظفا
وبين ليله وضحاها غادر عدد جديد من
الموظفين بعد ان حدد ماسك لهم موعدا
نهائيا لقبول ساعات طويله من العمل من دون
شروط ووفقا للتقارير اختار
75% انهاء الخدمه وهو ما سيترك اقل من الف
موظف في تويتر هذا الامر سيؤدي الى انهيار
تويتر وفق الجارديان التي اعتبرت انه بعد
مغادره عدد من المهندسين الرئيسيين لتويتر
هناك مخاوف كبيره من ان الموقع سيكون عرضه
للاعطال الفنيه بسبب النظام المعقد الذي
يقوم عليه تويتر افلاسه شركه تويتر امر
وارد ايضا لان عائدات تويتر السنويه من
الاعلانات تمثل 90 في المئه من اجمال
الايرادات اي اكثر من خمسه مليار دولار
لكنه
الايرادات قد تضرر بسبب التوقف المؤقت في
الانفاق من قبل العملاء الرئيسيين هذه
الازمه اكدها ماسك بعد ان اعلن عن انخفاض
كبير في عائدات الاعلانات في اعقاب عمليه
الاستحواذ محذرا من انهيار الشركه قائلا
انه من دون زياده في ايرادات الاشتراك قد
لا ننجو من الركود المقبل
محاسن حضاره العربيه
اهلا بك
وهذه المفاجاه الكبيره غير معني بتويتر
ردود الفعل ان كان على عودته او على هذا
التلك في التعاطي مع هذه المنصه
تحيه لك ميسون بالفعل خبر رفع الحظر عن
ترامب هي هو اخر الاخبار المتعلقه بالهم
ماسك وتويتر
مجرد ما اعلن عن رفع الحظر كان هناك ردود
فعل رافضه ومؤيده بالنسبه للرافدين
يعتبرون ان ترامب الان اصبح لديه طبعا هذا
هذه الاراء كانت قبل ان يعلن انه لن يعود
يقولون ان ترامب الان اصبح لديه منصه همم
يمكنه التواصل مع مليارات الناس وقالوا
اضافوا ايضا بانه اذا بث على تويتر نشر
على تويتر ما ينشره على منصته همم
فان تويتر سيتحول الى منصه للكراهيه
التحريض ودعت عدد من المنظمات الحقوقيه
المدنيه هنا همم المعلمين الكبار الشركات
الكبرى في الولايات المتحده الى وقف
اعلاناتهم على تويتر همم رفضا له عوده
ترامب هذه كانت ضد عوده ترامب في المقابل
هناك من يعتبر ان هذه العوده هي
الديمقراطيه وانتصار ايضا لحريه التعبير
عن راي الذي التي قالها وتحدث عنها الى
مصر اكثر من مره بان تويتر هو منصه
للتعبير عن الحريه عن عن حريه التعبير
عفوا ولكن هو يرفض ان يكون هناك همم ترويج
للكراهيه وقال سابقا بان اي تغريده
ستروبوس للقراه هي سيتم ابطالها ولكنه لن
يحذفها ستبقى موجوده على تويتر ولكن لمن
يريد ان يبحث عنها ولكن لن يتم الترويج
لها
مراسل العربيه
لاحقه من سان فرانسيسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
الان مشاهدينا ننتقل الى الملف الاوكراني
وفي ظل تمسك اوكرانيا بعدم التفاوض مع
روسيا لما تسحب روسيا كل القوات من
اراضيها يبدو ان الحل السياسي لا يلوح في
الافق وان صوت الميدان هو الاقوى طبعا هذا
بحسب الاوكران نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ان القوات قوات بلاده قد تصل الى شبه
جزيره الجرم التي او القرم التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا بحلول 25 من ديسمبر وتنهي
الحرب بحلول الربيع واشاره هافري لوف الى
عدم استبعاد احتمال وقوع احداث مفاجاه لا
يمكن التنبؤ بها في الاشهر المقبله في
الداخل الروسي طبعا في اشاره ربما الى
تطور سياسي غير متوقع قد يؤثر على الكرم
طبعا هذه التصريحات الميدانيه تزامنت ايضا
مع
تحذير من الرئيس الاوكراني
الدفاع والامن الغربيه قال فيه انهاء
الحرب مع روسيا لا تضمن السلام دعوني
تبحث روسيا الان عن هدنه قصيره وفتره راحه
لاستعاده القوه قد يسمي شخص ما هذا نهايه
الحرب لكن مثل هذه المهله لن تؤدي الا الى
تفاقم الوضع واي افكار سيئه بشان تنازلات
عن الارض او سيادتنا لا يمكن ان يطلق
عليها سلام
التنازلات الى اخلاقيه ستؤدي الى دماء
جديده
وصادقا لا يمكن الا ان يكون نتيجه تدمير
كامل للعدوان الروسي هناك 10 جنود في صيغه
السلام الاوكرانيه هذه هي التحديات التي
ينبغي ان نتغلب عليها من اجل امن اوكرانيا
واوروبا والعالم
هذه صيغه سلام للعالم اقترحت اوكرانيا
بالضبط صيغه سلام كهذا لقد قدمتها الى
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده وقمه مجموعه
العشرين واطلب منكم العمل على تنفيذ هذه
الصيغه وهذا هو السبيل الوحيد لسلام حقيقي
الامن الايراني يفقد مئات المتظاهرين
ابصارهم باستهداف مباشره لاغاثه المحتاجين
ردا على تفجير اسطنبول تركيا تدق ساعه
الحساب سوريا الديمقراطيه تحذر من فاجعه
اطلاق النار لا يضمن السلام ويؤكد ان
روسيا تبحث عن استراحه لقواتها
وبعد غياب دمع عامين ترامب يعود الى تويتر
وشركات تنتظر موجه اقالات واستقالات جديده
اهلا بكم مجددا ونكمل نشره الظهيره واخبار
الظهيره من المؤتمر مؤتمر المناخ حيث اقر
المندوبون خلال جلسه عامه ختاميه فجر
اليوم في شرم الشيخ انشاء صندوق لتعويض
الخسائر والاضرار التي تتكبدها الدول
الناميه جراء التغير المناخي حتى رئيس
المؤتمر وزير الخارجيه مصر سامح شكري حتى
المندوبين من حوالي 200 بلد مجتمعين منذ
اسبوعين في منتجع شرم الشيخ المصري حتى هم
على اعتماد القرارات التي ستعرض عليهم
طبعا صعوبات دفعت الامين العام للامم
المتحده للاعراب عن خيبه امله من الاتفاق
حول الانبعاثات التي تم التوصل اليه في
مؤتمر الاطراف حول المناخ قتال شدد على ان
العالم لا يزال في قسم الطوارئ يحتاج الى
خفض جذري للمنبعثات مشيرا الى ان هذه
مساله لم يع مؤتمر المناخ بحسب تعبيرهم
الى اخبار الرياضه في اخبار الظهيره يشهد
ملعب البيت الواقع على بعد 60 كيلو متر
شمال الدوحه العاصمه القطريه حفله افتتاح
كاس العالم حفل من المنتظر ان يستقطب
60,000 متفرج ومن المقرر ان يشارك في حفل
الافتتاح فنان كوري جنوبي مشهور جدا كما
يشارك من الجانب العربي ميريام فارس وعدد
من
المطربين الاجانب
وطبعا قبل ساعات من كاس العالم خبر محزن
لمحبين نجم هجوم المنتخب الفرنسي كريم
بنزيما اكدت وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه غيابه
عن قائمه المنتخب الفرنسي في هذه البطوله
بنزيما كان غادر تدريبات المنتخب الفرنسي
امس حيث يعاني من الاصابه مؤخرا من ناديه
ريال مدريد وجدير بالذكر ان هذا المونديال
كان من المصدر ان يكون الاخير لكريم
بنزينه البالغ من العمر 34 عاما
من جهه اخرى هسه هلا النجم ليونيل ميسي
تمارين الارجنتين بمفرده وذلك قبل ثلاثه
ايام من مواجهه السعوديه في افتتاح
مباريات المجموعه الاولى كان افضل لاعب في
العالم سبع مرات والباحث عن لقبه الاول في
المونديال لم يخد تمارين الجمعه بعد وصول
المنتخب الى الدوحه مكتفيا بالعمل داخل
صاله اللياقه البدنيه بينما خاض اللاعبون
تمرينا جماعيه
هذا وقد عاد الدوله البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى تدريبات منتخب البرتغال قبل
المباراه الاولى لنهائيات كاس العالم ضد
غانا طبعا بالجوله الاولى من دور
المجموعات رونالدو كان قد غاب عن مباراه
البرتغال ونيجيريا الوديه والتي انتهت
بفوز بلاده برباعيه نظيفه بسبب مشكله في
المعده وايضا في الامعاء لكن البرتغالي في
الحصه التدريبيه ليوم السبت عادا للعمل
بشكل طبيعي في المعسكر التدريبي طبعا تقام
مباراه البرتغال وغانا الخميس المقبل
لحساب المجموعه الثامنه
كان قد اكد نجم مانشستر سيتي ومنتخب
البرتغال برناردو سيلفا ان الاجواء ممتازه
في المنتخب البرتغالي عشيه انطلاق العرس
العالمي وذلك رغم الجدل الذي تسبب به
انتقاد كريستيانو رونالدو لفريقه مانشستر
يونايتد ولمدربه الهولندي وانهلت الاسئله
على سيلفا بشان رونالدو الذي يبدو في
طريقه للانفصال عن الشياطين الحمر لكن
نسيب اكد ان زميله متحفز وجاهز
عليه الصلاه والسلام
الرياضي منير رحومه اهلا بك استاذ منير
اسمحلي ان ابدا بما وصفا قبل قليل بعرس
اليوم والحفل الافتتاح
بالتاكيد طبعا اليوم
اصبح حقيقه الحلم الذي ينتظره كل الشعب
العربي والخاصه الجماهير المحبه لكره
القدم ان تقام كاس العالم في دوله عربيه
على اراضي عربيه اليوم الحلم اصبح حقيقه
وهذا الحلم هو سيكون اليوم يعني شعار حفل
الافتتاح كاس العالم قطر 2022 ضد ريمرز
الحاليون اليوم اصبحوا في ملعب البيت الذي
سوف يحتضن حفل الافتتاح حدث كبير جدا
تعيشه الدول العربيه همم
ولكن خبرنا اكثر عن الرسائل ربما خلال هذا
الحفل وما الذي نقراه منها اليوم
صحيح العديد من الرسائل الايجابيه همم
رسائل مهمه اولا للتعريف كل العالم
بالحضاره العربيه والتراث العربي الاصيل
يعني رسائل لمده نصف ساعه خلال الحفل سوف
تركز على اهميه همم التالف والتعايش بسلام
بين مختلف سكان العالم ان الارض على
العربيه مفتوحه لكل الشعوب للتعايش بسلام
وبامن
ونبذل الاختلاف والتعصب رسائل ايجابيه
كلها تحمل معاني همم مهمه للانسانيه اليوم
في هذه الظروف التي يعيشها العصيبه التي
يعيشها العالم رسائل همم ايضا همم توجه
همم يعني تعرف العالم بالتراث العربي
الاصيل في خاصه في دول الخليج وهذه يعني
طبعا رسائل بحضور زعماء وقاده دول العالم
فاعتقد ان اليوم يعني رسائل كبيره من
العالم العربي الى ولكن سيد منير انا اقول
بانه نتمنى الحظ الوفير للمنتخبات العربيه
ولباقي ايضا من دبي الاعلام الرياضي منير
رحومه شكرا جزيلا لك
نبقى في الرياضه ولكن في موضوع استطاعت
العربيه من خلاله الدخول والتجول في مسقط
راس بنزيما حيث اقام له سكان تكريما بحصدي
لقب افضل لاعب في العالم التفاصيل مع
الزميل فادي الدهون هنا
افضل لاعب كره قدم في العالم حي متواضع
وفقير بل تصنفه السلطات الفرنسيه على انه
خطير امنيا لكن هنا لا مظاهر امنيه بل فرح
عارم عبر عنه السكان بهذا الرسمي لابن
الحقيقي بعد نيل كريم الكره الذهبيه غدا
حي مقصدا الكثير من الناس و لفنانين راب
الشباب ايضا
[موسيقى]
اليوم رونالدو
يساوي
طفولته كان كريم يتدرب على جدار في النادي
اصبح اليوم مثل تعويذه للاعبين الصغار
وكان السبب الذي دفع صائدي اللاعبين في
نادي ليون العريق لترقي باب العائله وعرض
اول عقد الاحتراف عليه
ابن الاشتيا موديل
اسبانيا وفي امم اوروبا افضل لاعب في
العالم وصاحب الكره الاثمن الكره الذهبيه
القاب يفخر بها بنزيما وترسم فرحا غامرا
على وجه كل من عرفه طفلا صغيرا قبل 27 سنه
ونجما كبيرا في عالم كره القدم اليوم
فدهوك العربيه اليوم
للمره الاولى
عسكريه اعتياديه لسلاحيه البحريه الياباني
والامريكي في المحيط الهادئ على ما ذكرت
السلطات البريطانيه السفينه انضمت الى
المناورات التي استمرت 10 ايام
وننتقل الى خبر اخر اول هزيمه من 53 عام
خسر الرجل الاكبر عمرا في السياسه
الماليزيه مهاتير محمد خسر مقعده في
السباق البرلماني في الانتخابات النيابيه
فشل محمد البالغ من العمر 97 عام في
الاحتفاظ بمقعده والذي يشغله ل 53 عام في
هزيمه قد تمثل نهايه لمسييرته السياسيه
الممتده من عقود حل مهاتير محمد رابعا في
الانتخابات التي اجريت في دائره جزيره
لنكاوي الانتخابيه في اول خساره له من عام
69 كان الرجل اكد لرويترز انه سيتقاعد من
العمل السياسي اذا خسر هذه الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا طبعا الان يمكن ان اتحدث وعوده
الى الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب في
موضوع اخر يتعلق بالتحقيقات وزاره العدل
الامريكيه عينت مدعي مستقل استكمال
للتحقيقات الجاريه مع الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب اجراء رفضه ترامب بطبيعه
الحال التهمه اداره الرئيس بايدا بمحاوله
تاسيس القضاء طبعا البيت الابيض نفى علمه
المسبق بتعيين المحقق الخاص الا انه رفض
وبقوه هذه الاتهامات التهامات ترامب
الخاصه بمحاولات تاسيس القضاء كما ذكرنا
نتابعه
مرحله جديده دخلتها التحقيقات الجنائيه
التي يواجهها الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
تحتمل تاويلات كثيره على الاقل من جانبه
ثلاثه ايام على تقديم ترامب ترشيحه للسباق
الرئاسيه المقبل عين جاكسون المدعي العام
السابق لجرائم الحرب مستشارا خاصا جديدا
للاشراف على التحقيقات بكيفيه التعامل
الرئيس السابق مع الوثائق السريه ودوره
المزعوم في الهجوم على مبنى الكابيتال
تاكد ان ترشحترام
لاداره التحقيق والادعاء بشكل مستقله
مضيفا ان ذلك ما تقتضيه المصلحه العامه في
حالات استثنائيه كهذه لمنح جمهور الثقه
بالتحقيق
التعيين وصفه الرئيس السابق بوصمه عار
واسوء تاسيس للعداله في التاريخ الامريكيه
مرجعا السبب الرئيسي للخطوه الى تقدمه بكل
استطلاعات الراي كمرشحا للرئاسه وتمسك
بعدم المشاركه بالتحقيق نافيا ارتكابه اي
مخالفه بالاصل
وصلنا في خطوه وزاره العدل في خانه
الاستغلال الرهيب للسلطه وفق تعبيره
اجراء التحقيقات المطلوبه هو اي محاكمه قد
تنجم عنها بشكل مستقله مع العلم بانه من
سيقرر امكانيه مواجهه ترامب لتوها من
جنائيه وبالتالي عرق للطرقه للبيت الابيض
وبحسب مراقبين فان تكلفه مستشار خاص يضمن
الحياده ويبعد بيضا عن اي شبهات في دور
يعرقل نجاح خصمه المحتمل في الانتخابات
المقبله
ومشاهدين هذه العوده لمشاركه البحريه
البريطانيه مع منى
عسكريه بحريه طبعا يابانيه وايضا امريكيه
من طوكيو معنى مفاده العربيه الى هناك
ميسون ويهد اهلا بك ميسون بدايه اهميه هذه
المناورات اولا بصوره عامه والرسائل منها
اهلا بك يا ميسون هذه التدريبات استمرت 10
ايام مع طبعا مشاركه اليابان الولايات
المتحده استراليا
وانضمت ايضا الان بريطانيا الى هذه
التمرينات هذه التمرينات التي استمرت 10
ايام
الضابطه التنفيذيه لسفينه البريطانيه قالت
بانها اتاحت فرصا كبيره لتعزيز التعاون
بين القوات البريطانيه والبحريه ايضا
اليابانيه بالاضافه طبعا الى الحلفاء
المشاركين في هذه التمارين اهميه هذه
التمرينات بانها تحاكي اي اختار همم او اي
سلاح يوجه الى هذه الدول وقلت ايضا
الضابطه التنفيذيه على هذه السفينه بانه
همم تم توثيق العمل بين الاطراف المشاركه
فيها من اجل تاكل من جيبوتي كل هذه الدول
لاي خطر السلاح من الممكن ان يوجه اليها
وطبعا ايضا تاتي في اطار هذا التوتر
الحاصل بسبب كوريا الشماليه وتهديداتها
وايضا اطلاق الصاروخ يعني منذ يومين همم
هذا الصاروخ البالستي بالاضافه الى العديد
من الصواريخ البالستيه التي همم طبعا
كوريا الشماليه اطلقتها وما زالت تهدد او
تصاعد ايضا هذا التهديد من اجل من اجل
طبعا هي تقول بانه رد بانه هي بتقول كوريا
الشماليه
التي تحصل الان
رئيس الوزراء الياباني لو تضعين في صوره
هذه التصريحات وهل التصريحات مباشره
وموجهه الى دول بعينها مثل كوريا الشماليه
او لا
طبعا بعد اطلاق هذا الصاروخ كان اكد رئيس
الوزراء الا ياباني بانه هذا الصاروخ وقع
في المياه الاقتصاديه اليابانيه تحدث بانه
لم يكن هناك من اضرار ولكن قال بان هذا
استفزاز غير مقبول وداع الدول الحنيفه
خاصه الولايات المتحده بريطانيا واستراليا
بان يتم التعاون الوثيق بين هذه الدول
والتنسيق الدائم بينهم من اجل ان يكونوا
جاهزين
لهذه الاستفزازات التي تقوم بها كوريا
الشماليه بالاضافه طبعا لي وزير الياباني
الذي قال بانه هذا الاستفزاز غير مقبول
ايضا هناك جلسه في مجلس الامن غدا بسبب
اطلاق هذه صحيح
طبعا مشاهدينا ترامب كان اعلن انه سيخوض
انتخابات الرئاسه المقبله انتخابات سينفسه
فيها على الاغلب الرئيس
والذي احتفل اليوم بعيد ميلاده الثمانين
ليصبح اول رئيس امريكي يحتفل بعيد ميلاده
ال 80 وهو داخل السلطانه متابع
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
الامن الايراني يفقدو مئات المتظاهرين
ابصارهم باستهداف المباشر ودعوات لاغاثه
المحتاجين
ردا على تفجير اسطنبول تركيا تدق ساعه
الحساب قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تحذر من
فاجعه
اطلاق النار لا يضمن السلام ويؤكد ان
روسيا تبحث عن استراحه لقواتها
وبعد غياب دمع عامين ترامب يعود الى تويتر
والشركه تنتظر موجه اقالات واستقالات
جديده
مشاهدينا اخبار الظهيره انتهت الان نلتقي
غدا مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]